F.F., she's cutting in front of you.
Hey, I said she cut in line.
I know.
For some reason,
I feel like the others
don't accept me here.
It's like they're looking down on me.
Don't cut, dumbass!
Tell her off.
I disagree with you.
It's not good to force something.
You have to change yourself
before seeking approval from others.
Isn't that right?
So, I decided to do the exact opposite
of what I usually do.
What's the opposite of coffee?
Tea?
That's right. Atroe's body,
which I took over, is craving coffee.
So I go with tea instead.
On purpose.
Does that make sense?
Instead of bread, I eat rice.
Use my non-dominant left hand
instead of my right hand to eat.
I'm trying to change myself
by doing the exact opposite.
Listen, F.F.
The wound where I got shot…
It hurts like hell.
I told you.
I can only fill the holes with plankton.
The rest is up to
your body's ability to heal.
-Got that?
-Damn.
Jolyne, what's the opposite of pork?
Maybe chicken, or even beef.
The opposite of pork is salmon.
Pigs lie around in mud all day.
Salmons swim against the current
to go upstream.
I love that.